this morning aspiring wall builder
Donald J Trump called the press to his
eponymous tower with a big announcement
he's got an idea for how Americans
should pay taxes his plan would mean no
income tax for anyone earning under
$25,000 a year reducing the number tax
practice to four limiting income taxes
for businesses at 15% and eliminating
the estate tax or to use the ghoulish
cliched alternative label that the rich
people like to use the death tax here is
how the Donald himself described it I
wouldn't say populist at all I would say
I'm a man of common sense I'm cutting
taxes I'm going to create a lot of jobs
I'm going to get rid of a tremendous
amount of waste and I'll tell you what
the waste that I get rid of the waste
that I get rid of is going to have a
huge impact and I'm not even putting
that in my numbers so I think it's going
to be terrific
now the question is always when we get a
candidate who puts forward a policy
proposal I ask you is this terrific
policy or andor terrific politics let's
take the policy first job down it is a
fraud a total fraud fraud he's talking
about giving tax cuts to the middle
class and and helping the the working
poor it is crumbs for them and caviar
for the rich he will say he's ending the
carried interest loophole but he lowers
the top rate to 25 percent doesn't
really end it ends the estate tax which
goes to about one-half of one percent of
the richest Americans this is an
absolute it's actually traditional GOP
supply-side politics Grover Norquist
loves it and this is and this is where I
think it gets to the politics question
right I mean first let's the Trump's
posturing as a populist as a different
kind of Republican last night 60 minutes
ask these questions but with some
concern this might actually be kind of
almost a liberal tax plan turns out to
not be true as you have laid out it is
it is a plan to the right of jeb bush's
tax plans or right to the right of
almost anybody's tax plan who's
currently in the Republican nominating
contest it might therefore be okay
politics for Donald Trump because the
truth is a populist populist style
twinned with a real hardcore Republican
conventional policy agenda that could be
a winner well it could be but let's not
forget he also cynically he is going to
go he's not going to cut entitlements
that might be a winner too
he's going to massively increase defense
spending and then he's gonna have a huge
revenue losing tax plan that's what a
lot of debt there yeah a lot of debt
there I got to say I'm not sure there's
any way I can imagine this week revenue
neutral although he claims it